>>Gabe Cohen: Hi, everybody. Welcome to Taking
Android to Work. My name is Gabe Cohen. I'm
the product manager for Android Enterprise.
And I have with me Fred Chung, who's a developer
advocate on Android, and Andy Standler, who's
one of the senior engineers on Android.
We're going to talk today about enterprise
mobility, Android's enterprise features, and
how you can extend Android in the enterprise.
But first, a little bit of housekeeping. And
you've been through this for many, many sessions
now. You've got our links to provide feedback
on the session, whether or not you find it
useful. And also to submit questions via moderator.
Of course, we'll take live questions also.
So let's get started.
As you've been hearing over the last couple
of days, Android is growing very, very fast.
There are hundreds of devices, hundreds of
carriers, 400,000 devices being activated
a day, and over 100 million device activations
to date.
But you might not know it's also growing fast
in the workplace. But why is that?
You could point to that consumer growth as
the source of the momentum. But how does it
actually translate into workplace acceptance?
Well, let's think back a second.
It used to be the case that the I.T. department
bought smartphones. They'd buy hundreds and
thousands of devices. They'd set them up,
they'd give them to the users, they'd support
the users, they'd pay for the data plans and
so on. And then really good smartphones started
coming out that were targeted directly at
consumers and consumers started buying the
smartphones themselves. And some of those
consumers, namely, C-level executives at Fortune
500 companies started demanding that they
take those phones to work. Because nobody
wants a cool personal smartphone and a lame
corporate phone; right?
But to make that work, a phone needs to do
a lot of things.
Uh-oh. I still have a printer update. That's
amazing.
Sorry.
Anyway, in order to make that work, the device
needs to do a lot of things. It needs to meet
your home needs, you personal needs, your
social needs; it needs to meet your work and
your productivity needs; and it needs to meet
the needs of the CIO and the I.T. department.
Companies have a really big incentive to work
with their employees to accept their personal
phones because there's a lot of money to be
saved in both the hardware and the data plans.
Let's talk about how a company decides to
accept a mobile platform.
So let's put on our CIO hats for a second
and funny-looking glasses, bow ties, whatever,
and talk about the main concerns a CIO has
when accepting a new platform.
First of all, they're securing the corporate
data from loss or from theft. There's managing
you in and more diverse devices at scale.
And then there's apps, which is all about
the CIO's responsibility to make the company
more productive with new technology.
So let's take a second and walk through each
of these in a little more detail.
So first of all, the CIO needs to make sure
that the company's data is secure. And even
an employee with the best of intentions is
a threat to your data security. Because after
four drinks, he leaves his phone on the bar.
[ Laughter ]
>>Gabe Cohen: And he probably doesn't read
your memos that you send out about setting
a password and a lock screen for your devices.
Maybe he takes that phone to Starbucks and
logs onto the corporate intranet, you better
hope you're using SSL or VPN. In the worst
case, a competitor could find your vice president's
home, break into her car, steal her phone,
rip out the battery, put it in a faraday cage.
You get the idea.
Secondly, the CIO needs to figure out the
processes that are required to manage all
of these new devices, more diverse devices
at scale. Which means they need to set processes
for the users, how do they know whether or
not their phone is accepted? How do they set
it up? How do they bring it online on the
network and to the intranet, the mail service,
et cetera?
They need to define security policies for
the company or potentially for individual
organizations within the company that have
different security needs depending on the
types of information they handle. They need
to figure out how to support more users over
time on different kinds of devices, if they
have problems using the device, if they forget
their password, which is extremely common,
if they lose it. And then, finally, over time,
they need to keep a holistic view of the entire
fleet.
Finally, the CIO needs to make the company
more productive with the new technology. And
that means they need to look at the key software
that their employees use, they need to look
at whether or not there are mobile interfaces
or apps available for that software, and then
decide whether or not to build mobile apps
for that software or buy them. And once they
have the software, they have to get it to
the users. How do they distribute the apps
to those users' devices? And then over time,
how do they maintain them?
And in some cases they need to lock down the
applications users can use on devices because
there might be liability issues. You know,
with users consuming mature content or consuming
lots of data that might come back in a corporate
overage bill. They might also have regulatory
issues they need to comply with.
So now that we've looked at those three major
areas the enterprises consider when deciding
to decide a platform, I want to talk quickly
about how Android actually addresses those
needs.
So Android is first and foremost focused on
users. We want to build hardware and software
that users lust after. We also want to build
the ecosystem as big and as fast as possible,
because it pays all these dividends in terms
of network benefits; right? We get more developers,
we get more applications, more devices, and
more user choice.
But there's a lot of money being spent in
the enterprise. Enterprises spend millions
and millions of dollars on hardware, software,
services, support, and so on. And there are
actually a lot of users in the enterprise
as well. Like, a lot of consumers actually
have jobs. And those are the users that we're
focused on here. We want to unlock their ability
to take their personal phone to work and use
it for both purposes.
But it's really important that we keep the
enterprise support that's in Android open
and extensible, because we want OEMs and software
vendors to go out there and make money in
the enterprise today. And they're actually
doing that. If you look at the Motorola, they
released an enterprise-focused device, the
Droid Pro. It has a better keyboard for business
usage.
You can look at NitroDesk. They released TouchDown,
which is a drop-in Outlook replacement, essentially,
for your phone that's available in Market.
It's extremely popular.
One of our partners, Mobile Iron, actually
has added Android support to the platform
to their Mobile Device Management Suite.
So we have a lot of partners out there doing
different things. And especially when you
look at the OEMs and the carriers, they're
doing a lot of interesting things and moving
potentially in a lot of different directions.
It's a good thing, because they're out there
actually getting devices into the workplace
today. But Android actually needs to introduce
standards over time into the platform so that
the enterprise features that are there for
developers are exposed in a consistent way.
So next I want to talk just briefly about
the features we've actually added to the platform
over time.
So way back in Donut, we introduced some of
the first relevant features, secure Wi-Fi
and VPN support. In Eclair, we added basic
exchange support for e-mail and contacts.
In Froyo, we completed the exchange support
by adding calendar. And then we added a really
important piece we're going to talk about
again -- talk about in a minute, which is
device policy management, which is about setting
up security features and requirements for
the phones. In Gingerbread, we added more
productivity features into GMail and calendar
and contacts. And in Honeycomb, we added some
really interesting stuff. We added more security
policies that control passwords. We added
support for device encryption, which is one
of the most frequently requested features
we have been getting from enterprise customers.
We added global address list support across
the suite of apps and in contacts for both
exchange and Google Apps.
So that's kind of an overview of how Android
is approaching the enterprise, the features
that we built, how we're prioritizing things.
And I hope that's been useful to you guys.
Next I'm going to hand it over to Andy Standler,
who's going to talk a little bit about device
policy management framework.
>>Andy Stadler: Thanks, Gabe.
Okay. Hi, my name is Andy Standler, and I'm
going to sort of address the fact that this
is a developers' conference and dive into
a little bit more of a development topic,
actually. And that is how you, as developers,
can tackle one of the problems that Gabe touched
on. And that is how can your app ensure that
it is running on a secure device. Or how can
your app control the aspects of your device
configuration to make sure that it is in a
secure environment.
Now, what kind of apps need this? I've kind
of broken it down into three really broad
categories. The first is apps that are really
the client end point of fleet management solutions.
And I've listed a couple here that you're
almost certainly familiar with. These are
the apps that provide an administrator with
the ability to control and monitor the security
status of a whole fleet of devices.
Now, some apps don't work with a server, but
they really need to also provide the assurance
that they are on a secure device and that
the data that they're collecting or presenting
is safe, remains safe, and is presented only
to the intended users.
And, finally, there are apps that provide
device management or fleet management types
of capabilities, but they are really oriented
toward single users.
Now, these are really just a loose collection
of overlapping suggestions. There are plenty
of other kind of interesting ways to deploy
and use these devices. And our challenge was
to enhance the Android framework in a way
that could support applications like these,
applications you can come up with, and, most
importantly, support multiple applications.
We've always believed strongly that Android
apps need to coexist peacefully with each
other. And security-oriented applications
really are no different.
So in order to support applications like the
ones I have described, we developed the Device
Policy Manager. And in the next few slides,
I'm going to show you what it does and how
you can write apps to use it.
So the first thing to tell you about is policies.
And these are the actual specific controls
that an app can place on a device. So you're
very familiar with policies, things like require
a screen lock password, require the device
to be encrypted. These are policies.
We introduced policies in Froyo. We enhanced
and added to them in Honeycomb. And we are
going to keep on adding policies as releases
continue.
And if you want to think about where -- the
roles involved, there are really these roles:
Applications that you write are going to set
the policies. The Device Policy Manager is
the APIs and the framework for maintaining
those policies and communicating them among
the various modules. And, finally, the rest
of the system is supposed to obey the policies.
Now, let's look at one sort of interesting
aspect of this, which is, what happens when
you have multiple apps that are trying to
control policies?
When there are multiple sources of security
policies, we need to consider what I call
the principle of increasing security. Any
app can make or set policies that increase
the security of the device, but no app can
use policies to reduce the security of the
device.
In practice, this really just boils down to
a simple set of rules for each policy. So,
for example, passwords need to keep getting
longer and stronger or more complex. And things
like a screen-lock timeout would get shorter
and shorter, which makes for a more secure
device.
You might be wondering if the policies I'm
describing or the concept of policies is really
just a different version of Android permissions.
And they're a little different in a subtle
but important way.
Policies -- I'm sorry, permissions are -- they
basically let your apps do things that are
risky or may be costly or might expose data.
Policies, on the other hand, actually increase
the security of the device. So they kind of
-- the more policies, you're moving in the
more secure direction.
Anyway, now, with these policies in place,
we just have to define an API and a work flow
for using them.
Now, in order for you to create a policy management
application, you need to add the following
three elements. The first is that you need
to explicitly define the policies that you're
going to enforce.
The second is you write a receiver. This is
very similar to a broadcast receiver. And
this is so that you may be notified of the
changes to the device security status.
And third, you're going to write a policy
controller. And this is where you actually
write your own code which interacts with the
Device Policy Manager to monitor and control
the security status of your device and also
to enforce whatever business logic is associated
with that security.
So now we're going to take a look at a sample
implementation. We'll start with the policy
declarations. This is simply a list, like
I said, of the policies that your app intends
to enforce. And each policy directly corresponds
to one or more API calls. If you don't declare
the policy, you may not make these calls.
And we're going to see later this same list
will be shown to the user in a system activity.
But, of course, it'll be formatted quite a
bit more nicely.
And the next thing you're going to implement
is a receiver. And this is where your app
can be notified of changes to device security
state. I added one little note here, because
this is one of these things that -- just one
of these general Android programming reminders,
is that notifications come in on the UI thread.
We always have to be careful and not get ANRs
and things like that.
But the most important thing is, this is where
you learn about the changes to the device
status.
And a little later, we'll talk about the things
that you might do when you respond to these.
Okay. So, finally, we're going to implement
a policy controller. This will take a few
slides, but we'll walk through the pieces
of a sort of sample typical policy controller.
In this case, it's going to be one that requires
a specific policy for your device, that the
user must have created either a PIN or a password
for their screen lock.
So the first thing we need to do is find out
if our app has even been activated as a device
policy administrator. And if our app hasn't
been activated, we will not be able to make
any policy calls at all.
So the next step is to ask the user to activate
our app. And this is the place where policies
are like permissions. They are all exposed
to the user. The user sees them and accepts
them before we can proceed. We don't allow
just any app to start enforcing policies on
the device.
So when you make this start activity call,
it presents a system activity which explains
to the users what they're about to authorize.
And the app only receives permission to assert
the policies if the user clicks "activate."
Even though this is a system activity, your
app does have a chance to insert some text,
which gives a chance to tell the user what's
about to happen and why. And, by the way,
the user might help cancel here. What do you
do? We'll talk about it a little later. But
the simplest thing to say is that you need
to be ready to keep trying. If you need to
get your device to a secure state, you need
to be able to retry this process until the
user gets there. And, obviously, you're not
going to want to present the secure data or
make the secure connections or whatever it
is that your app does until they get through
all these steps.
Now, once we have been activated, we can start
working with the specific policy APIs.
This next step highlights an important concept,
which is that there are many policies where
just because you've set a policy, it doesn't
actually mean the device has become more secure.
So, for example, in this case, we can set
a policy. We can require the user to enter
a PIN or a password. But until they actually
go through the process of entering a PIN or
a password, the device isn't really as secure
as we want it to be. So here you see in this
code the first call sets the policy. And then
the second call asks the question, "Has the
user done what they need to do to reflect
the policies we've set?"
And in the case that they haven't done it
yet, we need to again set the policies we
want and do what we need to do to get the
user to make the changes. And in this case,
we're going to use standard start activity
call to send an intent, launch the setting
screen where the user can enter a new PIN
or password.
Now, normally, the user can choose from four
types of screen lock: None, pattern, PIN,
or password. But now, because we've established
a policy, the user will only be allowed to
choose a PIN or a password. So this is a direct
example of the policies that you've set affecting
the behavior of the system.
Now, once again, this is a place where the
user might not continue. They might hit back
or home or get a phone call or -- anyway,
they don't get past the step and they don't
finish creating the PIN or password. So once
again, this is one of those places where you
need to be ready to sort of restart or dealing
with this.
Before we wrap up, I would just like to cover
a few issues that are pretty important when
you are developing device policy applications.
First, as I've been mentioning before, there's
no denying that it does take a few steps to
get through the process of getting a device
to a sufficiently secure state. You need to
account for the fact that the user might not
get through all the steps the first time.
And your policy controller needs to be able
to restart the process at any point in the
sequence. And your design should focus on
moving the device step by step towards the
sufficiently secure state.
So, to use an example, in the platform e-mail
application, where we walk through this exact
same set of steps, anytime the user exits
before the completion of the sequence, we
post a notification that says there's a security
-- security steps are required. But then we
just leave it there, let the user respond
to the notification, and at that point, bring
them back into the sequence.
The other thing you might consider is through
the use of dialogues or other ways of communicating
with the user, tell them what they're about
to do. Because, for example, if you just suddenly
present a password entry screen, they might
not understand why. So dialogues, notification
texts, these are all your friends here.
Next, there are going to be times when the
security level of the device actually decreases.
An example here is that some of the newer
policies we've added allow you to set device
PIN codes or passwords that have expirations
on them. These are designed to force the user
to enter a new one, say, every 30 or 60 days.
Now, if they allow those codes to expire,
your device is not really secure at this point,
because it's using an old code. So the device
is now in a less secure date than your app
wants it to be. However, it's really up to
you -- again, this is a business logic question.
It's really up to you what to do at that point.
And, finally, if you are implementing account-based
policy applications and if you support multiple
accounts, then you're going to be partially
responsible for the increasing security notions
that I described earlier. Make sure you don't
let any one of your accounts reduce the security
levels that was required by any of your other
accounts.
Now that I've covered the things that you
need to do when you implement a device administrator.
Fred Chung is going to show you a demo app
that actually walks you through a few of these
steps.
[ Applause ]
>>Fred Chung: Thanks, Andy.
Hello, everyone.
I'm Fred Chung. I'm a developer advocate on
Android. I work with a lot of external developers,
and my focus area is enterprise.
Well, Andy just talked about the detailed
implementation of the device policy management
API. In this section, I'm going to do a demo
that shows a practical application of the
API.
What -- the use case is actually pretty straightforward.
We are trying to enhance the security of an
internal application.
Well, by internal application, it can really
be referring to any applications containing
sensitive information. Well, for example,
your HR application, where it contains my
salary information, I really want to secure
that kind of information.
Typically, those applications may already
have an app-specific password requiring users
to authenticate. Here's the problem. Can I
see a show of hands, how many of you have
your screen-lock password set up? Including
the device you got yesterday.
All right. As it turns out, more than half
of smartphone users don't have their screen
lock set up. For those of you that didn't
raise your hand, I urge you to please set
it up after this session.
So back to the demo.
We're trying to, you know, perform a demo
that's aiming to enhance the security of the
application by ensuring the proper screen
lock is set up.
Well, before diving into the demo, let's have
a, you know, quick overview of the high-level
architecture of the application.
As you can see on the screen, in the middle
is the Android client in the tablet form factor.
On the right is an admin server that's sitting
somewhere in the cloud. For this demo application,
the admin server is built on Google App Engine
for Java. But in reality, it can be based
on any technology stacks. It doesn't really
matter.
The admin server exposes a couple of interfaces.
It exposes an HTML administrative interface,
allowing system administrators to go in and
define security policies. And what I mean
by "security policies" is that they can define
such things as what's the minimum length of
my password, does the password have to be
PIN type or alphanumeric or pattern or so
on and so forth.
Now, the second interface that is exposed
by the administrative server is a Web service
interface in order to facilitate two-way communication
between the Android client and the server.
Okay. Let's jump right into the demo.
Right here is -- I'm using this laptop to
access -- I'm sorry. Can we switch to demo?
>>Gabe Cohen: You're on.
>>Fred Chung: All right.
Can we switch back to demo, please.
On your right, I'm looking at my admin server
through Chrome browser. And right here, I
am working on a Motorola XOOM, obviously running
on Honeycomb. And this icon here is the demo
app.
Let me go to the admin server first. I'm going
to go in and log in as a user, a test user.
All right. I'm looking at the administrative
interface. It's a pretty clean UI. It is an
admin interface allowing administrator to
go in and define security policy.
Let's go ahead and set up a test security
policy, say, requiring PIN of minimum of four
digits in length. I'm going to go ahead and
save it. Now it's persisted to Google App
Engine.
Now I'm going to go back to the Android client
right here. Before launching, I want to say
that when you launch the app, it's going to
present you with a series of setup steps.
Here's the first step. It contains a bunch
of instructions, basically, telling me to
go to the admin server and set up a security
policy. Since I've already done that, I'm
going to go back to the Android client and
click "next."
Now it shows me the list of accounts that
are already set up on the device. And I'm
just going to and click on the one account
that I have set up.
Now, the app is about to perform a number
of steps outlined in Andy's section. In reality,
those steps will probably complete within
a fraction of a second.
So -- and, therefore, in order to make it
-- in order to make this demo more meaningful
and make this demo easier to follow by everyone,
we have deliberately introduced a number of
processes requiring human intervention in
between steps just to make sure the concept
is clearly communicated across.
The next step that I'm going to perform is
to synchronize the security policy from the
server. It's syncing. Through 3G network.
I'm glad that it works.
So it came back, brought back with the security
policy that we just set up, as you can see,
with PIN and a minimum password length of
four.
Notice the two question mark icons. Those
icons represent the fact that at this state,
the application doesn't know how to deal with
the security policy, because it hasn't been
activated as a device administrator. And I'm
going to go ahead and do that next by hitting
on this button "activate."
It then triggers a system dialogue box. And
as Andy also pointed out earlier, that in
this system dialogue box, you can put in some
customized message to make -- get clearer
to the users what they are dealing with.
Now, at this point, there could be multiple
outcomes; right? The users could click on
"activate" or they could click on "cancel,"
or "back." So when you're dealing with an
application, you need to account for different
possibilities like that. Let's go back to
the activate screen. This is the same screen
we just looked at. And let's now go ahead
and activate it. The application has been
activated as a system administrator. As you
notice on the -- for the icons, they switch
from question marks to exclamation points,
meaning that the existing password, which
doesn't exist on this device, the existing
no password set up on this device actually
is not sufficient as per the device policy.
And, therefore, it's presenting me with this
enforce password button. And I'm going to
click on this, which then triggers another
system intent to cause this password change
screen to appear.
If you remember, we defined a security policy
requiring a PIN type of password. You notice
how these selections of not secure and patterns
are disabled, because these are deemed less
secure than what's being required by the security
policy.
Let's go ahead and set up a pin-type password
of -- I'm not telling you.
Okay. Now, I have set up a PIN, and the device
recognizes that. Okay, the existing password
actually is sufficient for the -- what's being
defined by the security policy. And then I
can actually go ahead and access my security
-- my sensitive content.
Okay. Now that the device is properly set
up with a screen lock password, and I'm going
to show you what additional security can be
provided by the administrative API in conjunction
with cloud-to-device messaging. For those
of you who are not familiar with that, cloud-to-device
messaging is Google's implementation of push
messaging.
So -- and one of the criteria that Gabe talked
about in his talk that the CIOs need to really
care about device loss, theft, right, in the
event that happens, they need to have a way
to be able to remotely control the device
or remotely limit certain access. And that's
what this next part of the demo is about.
Let's go back to the admin server screen.
and navigate to remote admin interface. There
are two buttons. Okay, I'm going to just go
ahead and click on "lock device." What happens
after clicking on this is that it's going
to send a push message through C2DM to the
device and the device should react to it by
locking up the screen. Give it a few seconds.
>>Gabe Cohen: Show your hands.
>>Fred Chung: And,
of course, it's not working.
Let me give it one more try.
Well, it's not working. But I hope you get
the idea. All right. Can we actually switch
back to presentation mode, please.
All right. That's too bad. But, trust me,
it works.
[ Laughter ]
>>Fred Chung: Let's see. So that concludes
the demo, at least part of the demo, where
we just looked at a proof of concept on the
kinds of device management capabilities that
are possible.
What we just looked at is open source under
Google Project Hosting. I strongly encourage
you to have a look at it.
As developers, you can further expand on these
kind of capabilities by incorporating more
useful features such as remote wipe or password
resets.
Now, let's switch topics a little bit and
talk about a different thing.
One of the criteria CIOs consider is how to
get apps to users' devices. And let's talk
about that in the next section.
All right. Well, you may consider, you know,
a -- a system administrator of a company may
already have a collection of Android apps
that they want their users to install. Well,
some of these apps may be home-grown applications
that are highly proprietary to the business
flows of the business. And other types of
apps could be coming from third-party applications
that are publicly available. And these types
of applications are aimed to increase the
productivity of the workforce. For example,
TouchDown clients or Documents to Go or Angry
Birds. The last one may not make sense, may
not be such a good idea for certain businesses.
But I hope you get the idea.
For these types of publicly available apps,
right, you may want to direct your employees
to Android Market.
Let's see.
Okay. Well, Android Market is a great distribution
vehicle for distributing publicly facing applications
like what we just talked about. All you have
to do is to direct your users to a URL of
this format by including the package name
of the apps you want them to install. Using
Android Market, it gives you, you know, a
number of very useful features at no development
cost. Just to name a couple, hosting, hosting
is something that you don't need to worry
about. Also, any app updates are automatically
made available to the clients automatically.
However, internal app distribution may require
different solutions, because, well, in some
occasions, it doesn't really make sense for
others to see your internal applications.
Of the or you simply don't want others to
know the existence of certain private apps.
I'm going to show you two commonly used approaches
to distribute internal apps next.
Well, let's first have a look at side-loading.
I'm showing the audience here, the majority
of you should probably know what it is. It's
actually pretty straightforward. One pretty
common implementation is to host the APKs
on a server. It can be any server capable
of serving files. It can be Apache, or it
could even be based on Google Sites works
pretty well, too.
To install apps, users just need to point
their browsers to their URLs, or by simply
clicking on a hyperlink. When the download
completes, users taps on the APK, then the
standard app installation screens will take
over.
I also want to point out that in order for
side-loading to work, you need to make sure
that the unknown sources selection under settings
is checked. And since Android is an open system,
right, different OEMs or carriers may choose
to do different things. Some have chosen to
disable these settings altogether. And in
that case, side-loading may not be possible
on those affected devices. I just want to
make sure that people are aware of that.
Now, we talked about side loading just now.
With this approach, as you can imagine, as
your usage grows over time -- which, by the
way, is a good problem to have -- it may become
a little hard for your employees to manage
all of the URLs that they are given. Or sometimes
they may get all the URLs or the updates mixed
up.
In order to circumvent this, I'm going to
talk to you about a more sophisticated approach,
which is what I'm calling Internal App Directory.
Let's have a look at an overview of what this
Internal App Directory is all about.
In a typical deployment, it involves a -- you
know, a piece of server software and a corresponding
Android client.
If you look at this setup, it's not that different
from the demo setup that we just saw.
Through an administrative interface, system
administrators can publish a bunch of apps
that they want to be made available to their
users. Periodically, the Android app would
check in and say, "Hey, give me a list of
apps that my user can install."
The list would then get displayed on screen.
And at this point, the Android client can
perform a number of validations, for example,
he can check whether the list of apps already
exists on the device, and if so, flag the
user appropriately.
And if you need to build these kind of solutions
yourself, I strongly encourage you just to
bookmark this API doc for Package Manager.
This API -- this class exposes maybe a few
dozens of methods that allows you to gain
visibility into the various packages that
are already installed on the device.
Just to name a couple, this API gives you
visibility into the kinds of applications
that already exist on the device. And get
package archive info allows you to do something
like to check the validity of a downloaded
APK and stuff like that.
So when the user chooses a particular app
that they want to download, the actual download
of the APK happens, and it may get stored
in external storage. And lastly, it -- the
user -- when a user clicks on it, you can
fire a system intent to trigger the installation
flow.
Well, as you can see, this is a pretty involved
method. But over the long term, we believe
that if you -- if you wanted to invest in
these kind of solutions, you could build something
like this yourself, or you can purchase some
existing solutions out there in the market.
And the functionality is pretty similar, actually.
Well, I wanted to close with sharing a few
resources related to what we talked about
today. We are excited about Android's momentum
as a team in the consumer space, obviously,
and also in the enterprise sector.
In the enterprise sector, as well, we know
that we are not there yet. We have some more
work to do. And our team is actually working
pretty hard to make sure we become successful
in this area as well.
Lastly, for developers, we are looking forward
to seeing the kinds of innovations from this
audience right here. Of the and we'll hope
that you can build a pretty healthy business
and be very successful in the long run.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>>Fred Chung: So if you have any feedback,
please provide us. We'd love to hear your
feedback through this URL.
And I'm going to open it up for Q&A. For those
of you that are watching the stream -- the
live streaming, you can use the Google Moderator
for Q&A.
>>Andy Stadler: Who is broadcasting that.
>>Gabe Cohen: I am. I'll get it on the screen.
Just make that a little larger.
Let's start in the crowd. First question up
front.
>>> Are there any plans to implement user
accounts, say, different users could log in
with different passwords to a tablet, and
different applications would be enabled based
on that user's profile?
>>Gabe Cohen: I can take that.
That's something we're thinking about. I mean,
when we first started building Honeycomb and
thought about the tablet use cases, like,
passing advice between users on the couch,
it became apparent we might need something
like that in the future. We definitely also
get a lot of questions about people, again,
in the stool use scenario having different
security requirements, you know, not wanting
to impose the harder security requirements
to access their personal stuff. The and then,
of course, in the worst case, what happens
when they leave the company, what gets wiped.
So we're thinking about that. The but no specific
plans.
>>> Thank you.
>>Gabe Cohen: Yeah. Maybe from the back mike.
>>> Two questions. One is, is there any way
for an application to detect that a device
is rooted?
>>Fred Chung: I believe that there's a programmatic
way that I've seen once on stack overflow.
But I don't know off the top of my head what
that approach is.
>>> You've seen some app that has managed
to do it without asking the user any questions,
right, because the user will obviously say,
no, it isn't rooted, because they want access
to enterprise resources, so they won't give
you access they won't give me root access
to figure out whether the device is rooted
or not.
In this case, the user is the enemy in some
sense, because the enterprise --
>>Andy Stadler: I totally understand the question
you're asking. And it's an important question.
I don't think any of us can answer it.
>>Gabe Cohen: I think that's a question best
targeted at your security team, in case they
have ideas. And it may vary from device to
device also.
>>Andy Stadler: Yeah.
>>> And the other question was, are you planning
to support certificates for active sync?
>>Gabe Cohen: That's actually one of the questions
in the moderator queue.
We've been hearing that pretty frequently
also. We've noticed that users have had a
number of setup problems, because we don't
support certificate authentication in AOSP
exchange today. So that's something we're
actually working on.
>>> Thank you.
>>> So I have a question about the suggested
method for using the -- what you call the
internal app.
So it sounds like Google doesn't have a solution,
so you're just asking the developers that
build to come up with their own distribution
mechanism.
But it sounds like that's still going to require
side-loading to be enabled. And that doesn't
work at all on AT&T phones. And I don't know
on other carriers in other countries whether
they enable side-loading or not.
So -- and in many ways, to ask people to enable
side-loading kind of means less security to
them. So it seems counterintuitive that you
would do it that way.
So are there any plans to incorporate some
type of enterprise type of market in the future?
>>Fred Chung: Well, good feedback. I think
we can take that back and look into that further.
>>Gabe Cohen: We're definitely aware of those
problems. We're thinking about it. But I don't
think we have any solutions right now.
>>> Okay.
But then it will require side loading through
that mechanism; right?
>>Fred Chung: That's going to be the mechanism.
>>Gabe Cohen: That's correct.
>>Fred Chung: Yeah.
>>> Okay. Thanks.
>>> One of the things that you didn't mention
about the device admin is that once you enable
it, you're unable to uninstall the app.
Can you explain what the motivation is behind
that and why it's not documented.
>>Andy Stadler: Well, I'll answer the second
one first. Anything that's not documented
is certainly not intentional. And so, you
know, we welcome your feedback on places where
you're finding things missing in the documentation.
I think that's a fair statement on any API.
Now, in terms of why you can't uninstall an
active administrator, the answer is quite
simply because, you know, this is something
that has made assertions about the security
state of your device. And to simply uninstall
it would be to drop everything.
Now, the good news, however, is that you can
un- -- you can deactivate an administrator
app, at which point you can uninstall it.
And when you deactivate it, that's one of
those call-backs I mentioned. So, for example,
when you see that you've been deactivated,
that's one of those regressions in security
I was talking about, you know. If you're protecting
data, that's the time to wipe it or whatever.
>>> Right. But there's no security preventing
someone from deactivating it. So it just seems
like it's an extra check box a user has to
uncheck. It doesn't actually make it impossible
to uninstall or anything like that. It's just
an extra hoop you have to jump through first.
>>Andy Stadler: It's more than an extra hoop.
It's very explicitly a notification. So the
question is really, then, one of are we going
to block it forever, which I think is what
you're suggesting, or are we going to allow
the users to do that change, but at least
give the apps the notifications they need.
And the choice was made in the framework design
to take the latter course, which is we're
going to let the users do this -- You know,
this is, again, one of these things where
it's the user phone versus the corporate phone.
And the current, you know, direction is that
we, you know -- the user still has the control
of their phone. So we make sure that the corporate
data has an ability to detect that some changes
are happening and protect itself in whatever
way is necessary. But we're not currently
going to block that change entirely.
>>> Okay. The current error message is just
uninstall failed. It's not very useful.
>>Andy Stadler: I -- I'm not surprised.
>>> Thank you.
>>Andy Stadler: Very good feedback. Thank
you.
>>Gabe Cohen: Let me take a couple of the
moderator questions we have up here.
The first one I don't have a great answer
for. Are there plans to explicitly support
remote control apps so enterprise I.T. can
solve problems directly on employees' phones?
I think the answer is, today, I've seen some
vendors in this space actually partnering
with OEMs to expose the APIs they need. For
instance, one of the, you know, APIs I've
seen requested by people who do this kind
of support is, you know, I need to screen
cap or actually remote control, like, super
dangerous permissions that we haven't actually
figured out how we're going to expose, like,
if they would be in Market or what have you.
So we're thinking about this, but I don't
have any direct solutions today. I think in
some cases, a lot of our partners go to OEMs
to accomplish specifically what they need,
and then if they're really bold, they try
to create standards across the OEMs.
I think we still need to figure out which
are kind of the most common features we need
to support remote control, and then ultimately
we would like to incorporate them into the
platform.
Assuming that the user is informed that, they
give consent, and it doesn't neuter sort of
the user experience.
So for the second question up here, let me
jump down. Are there plans to implement a
VPN provider API at the platform level so
different VPN types could be installed through
the market?
This is also a case where people are solving
this problem today by going to OEMs. You know,
I think Cisco has an OEM partnership to provide
one of their VPN clients. There are a few
others. I know the Droid Pro package is something
else.
What we'd really like to see it that any vendor
has access to the users via the market. Again,
VPNs are extremely dangerous because they
can basically monitor all network traffic
when they are active. So we're actually working
on coming up with a solution that allows these
types of things to exist in user space, to
be distributed through Market. But working
on the usability and the experience is kind
of challenging for something that's so dangerous.
We need to make sure there are a lot of hoops
to jump through. Not unlike a device management
agent.
Back to the mic.
>> Is there any way to push configuration
on the phone, like VPN settings, for example?
>>Gabe Cohen: We are definitely thinking about
that in conjunction on working on improving
VPN support, but nothing specific.
>>Andy Stadler: Aren't some of the third parties
showing some things along those lines?
>>Gabe Cohen: I know some third parties have
gone to OEMs to get APIs or are using private
APIs because they have been side loaded with
root privileges by OEMs to do remote configuration.
I actually think this is one of the most important
areas that's going to be the most common across
devices that we will need to tackle in the
future, but we are not quite there yet.
Yeah.
>> Hi. If a company wanted to start using
your device manager API for internal applications,
they would want to ask questions about what
tools you have so we can test the application
to be sure they are actually secure.
>>Andy Stadler: I'm sorry, what's the question?
>> What testing tools are available?
>>Andy Stadler: None that I'm aware of, but
maybe you can tell me what you had in mind
and we can start to look at that.
>> A lot of companies will have like a corporate
I.T. policy that this has to go through some
kind of penetration testing.
>>Andy Stadler: Ah, I see.
>>Gabe Cohen: No, I don't know that we necessarily
have any vision for best practices for penetration
testing of Android apps. It might be a interesting
question for security team, also. Sorry.
>>Fred Chung: We will be glad to get more
information from you after this session.
>>Gabe Cohen: Next mic question.
>> Yes. Are there any plans to add programmatic
-- the programmatic ability that certificates
into the certificate store? Because currently
if a certificate has a C.A. that isn't built
into the Android OS, that presents a bit of
a problem.
>>Andy Stadler: Yeah, and so I know Gabe mentioned
earlier because we had another question about
certificates, and, really, what we are, in
fact, working on is we didn't want to just
jam certificates into one app. So there's
under way basically a more integrated solution
for dealing with certificates and things like
you are talking about are definitely part
of the work flows we are looking at.
>>Gabe Cohen: It's a known requirement. It's
not one certificate. It's many certificates
in order to bootstrap an email client. So,
yeah.
>> I have two questions. First one was in
the first part of the demo you had some policies
apply to a specific user account. So I guess
that implied that you could have different
policies for different accounts; is that correct?
>>Andy Stadler: Yeah, I think what he was
showing was an example where the server would
be tracking multiple accounts.
>> Right.
>>Andy Stadler: Not the device.
>> Not the device.
>>Andy Stadler: Right.
>> And the second one, you compared policies
with permissions. It's possible to create
custom permissions. Can you do that with custom
policies? Like can an application define a
custom policy?
>>Andy Stadler: No, and the reason is because
the policies don't work, they don't really
matter unless they have some teeth to them.
So a policy -- you can't just say I want to
make a new policy. You have to have the REST
of the OS obeying that policy.
So, really, the policies kind of come from
the bottom-up. A particular piece of the system
will -- The thing I didn't describe in the
device policy manager is there's two tracks
of API. There's the parts that apps would
use to assert policies and then there's the
parts that the REST of the system uses to
say, well, what are the current policies?
What do I need to do?
And so an app coming up with a policy won't
really help unless the system is watching
for that policy.
>> See, I am employed by a device manufacturer
so I have the ability to do the other part
of it so, I don't know, how would I implement
something like I only want certain users to
be able to change any settings, for example?
>>Andy Stadler: I see. If you are working
for an device manufacturer, of course you
have the ability to add methods to APIs. That's,
obviously, a capability you will have. Then
you would be talking about running apps that
would only be able to talk to that so you
probably want to use a shared library to distribute
for those devices.
These are the things that are fairly standard
in terms of how OEMs can add functionality
to specific devices. Nothing really special
here.
The main issue is, again, a policy doesn't
matter unless somebody is listening to that
point of impact. And I would obviously suggest
starting there.
>>Gabe Cohen: Thanks.
Yes.
>> If a user enables a policy, say, on a Froyo
phone, and the app declares something like
encryption which doesn't exist yet, is the
policy granted when the user upgrades? And
if it's not granted, does a user have to activate
again? Or if we upgrade our app to add a new
policy, do they have to walk through that
whole process again?
>>Andy Stadler: No. In fact, that's a really
great question, because you have actually
noticed one of the subtle but important distinctions,
is that when we present the list of policies
to the user, we do, in fact, list them explicitly.
And when they hit activate, we basically,
in the system, we copy down which policies
the user accepted.
Now, in this -- So, for example, I think you
hit a perfect one which is encryption. Let's
say they go through that on a Froyo device,
and then that device is it upgraded to Honeycomb.
Or Ice Cream Sandwich or something. The user
has only accepted the original and smaller
set of policies. And if the app was -- If
the app was upgraded to request some newer
policies, like encryption, it's going to continue
to run just fine until it tries to assert
the encryption policy.
So it's going to be bounded within the ones
which were accepted.
However, there is an API, I didn't show it
in the sample code but there is an API where
you can basically look at policies on a one--by-one
basis. You only need to use this if you have
upgraded that policy. And you can say, oh,
do I have this one? And if not, then, yes,
you do have to loop back and have them accept
it one more time.
Because it really -- I mean, you can't just
go do something based on this smaller set.
You have got to show it to the user and say
I need you to give me the OK to do this.
>> And does the user have to accept all the
policies again?
>>Andy Stadler: Yeah, it's Al an all or nothing.
There are no check boxes or anything like
that.
Yeah.
>>Speaker4: Front mic.
>> I have a question. If the application is
active, can it actually lower the requirements
for security? Example would be, for example,
e-mail application. If you had exchange account
and admin requires it, if you remove the account
it doesn't actually lower the policies.
>>Andy Stadler: So what happens is that -- remember,
I mentioned how there's policies, and then
there's the state of the device. And they
are linked but they are not 100 percent connected.
So to walk through a typical example, let's
say that you add an account that requires
a password. The user enters a password. You
have done all the right things. Now you have
got a device in that state.
Now, if they delete that account, we do all
the right things, we delete the data that's
associated with that account, we're going
to release those policy assertions. But we're
not going to actively change their password
on them.
So now the device is in a state where it has
a secure setting, such as a password or a
short screen lock or whatever, might still
be encrypted. But if the user happens to go
back to the settings for that setting, for
that device state, they will see that they
have regained the ability to reduce the security
on their own.
At this point it doesn't matter because we
no longer have the accounts in place.
>> OK. I was testing it on tablet and actually
after removing account it didn't allow me
to remove the PIN. So I guess --
>>Andy Stadler: It's either a bug or there
was some other source of policies.
So like, for example, I know when I have been
working with policy code -- and by the way,
I should have mentioned this. In the standard
API demos, which is our sort of sample app,
we have a whole page where you can manually
set and control policies. And sometimes I
will use that when I am exploring policy issue,
and sometimes I will forget that I left a
policy asserted in API demos, and then my
other app doesn't work right. It might not
be what happened to you, but most commonly,
that's the case unless there's a bug. Most
commonly it's that somebody else is setting
that policy.
>> This is just a built in mail application.
And the second question was talking corporate,
any support for -- support for proxy?
>>Gabe Cohen: Yeah. We implemented it in 3.1,
although I haven't seen that information publicized
anywhere, and I am hoping that it actually
made it into the release. I think it did.
So I believe it's there in 3.1, basic proxy
support, although we don't support auto configuration
or authenticated proxy, so it's not done.
And actually it's a little more nuanced than
that because Android apps can use different
network stacks. That proxy is applying to
browser and stacks that use I believe the
Java networking stack.
>>Andy Stadler: Don't look at me. I don't
know.
>>Gabe Cohen: I'm like, Andy, come on.
But not necessarily everything. It's fob to
bypass that, use lower level networking. Then
you don't actually integrate with that proxy
support. So we are still thinking about how
to complete that. There's actually a question
in moderator here about that that I was going
to talk to.
We also need to think about how to manage
proxy support but that's fairly dangerous
in terms of application control of system
proxy because, again, that allows monitoring
of all network traffic.
>> Is it then implemented per connection or
systemwide?
>>Gabe Cohen: It's per Wi-Fi network access
point.
>> Thank you.
>>Gabe Cohen: Yeah.
Back mic.
>> Quick question. Is there any plan to implement
the way that the applications are pushed from
the Web site, the Android Market Web site,
from something that will be agreed upon? You
know, I am thinking about Google Apps for
domain, for business. Once the policies agree
to the device, the admin push directly apps
to the devices that he has the right for.
>>Gabe Cohen: That's something we've actually
talked about. It seems like that would be
useful as a feature, although we haven't actually
come to agreement on how and if we should
expose something like that. Again, security
considerations in mind. But it's something
we are thinking about.
>> Okay. Obviously it has to be secure, but
once it's for the device that are linked to
Google Apps for business domain, there's already
a lot of policies that you can wipe directly
from the (inaudible). I was thinking from
this part of the domain, push from here.
>>Andy Stadler: One thing I want to just mention
is every time Gabe says we are thinking about
something --
>> It's done already?
>>Andy Stadler: -- he really means it. His
job is to maintain a very long list of priorities.
>>Gabe Cohen: And I sit in a cubicle and I
think about them.
>>Andy Stadler: And future requests that believe
me we know all of you have been asking for.
And it's one of Gabe's responsibilities is
keeping track of that.
So when he says we're thinking about it, we
really have had many discussions about it,
I want to let you know.
>>Gabe Cohen: I mean, that particular idea
could be a really great end-user experience,
so it is a good idea.
>> As a user during the week I may have a
bunch of applications that have very high
security demands, but on the weekends I may
want to not use these applications and have
lower security requirements, like not having
to put in a password every time the lock screen
comes in.
Now, at the moment I can set that up on Friday
night, I can remove these applications, remove
the security and reset it up on Monday morning.
>>Gabe Cohen: You can factory reset every
week, too.
>> Sure. Would like a "go secure" mode or
a per-application model be more appropriate
for that kind of user?
>>Gabe Cohen: So there's a few interesting
things we're seeing in the marketplace. Actually,
if you drop by the enterprise booth they are
doing something kind of interesting today
to address this sort of dual profile scenario.
It kind of gets to the earlier question we
got about profiles, too.
So, yeah, don't really have a great answer
for this today, but I think it's a real requirement.
Yeah, I mean, we've struggled with this when
we're enacting one policy for Google users
on Android devices, what kind of pass code
requirement, and the interaction between our
multifactor authentication, or device pass
codes. You want to work with the I.T. admin
to come up with the minimum acceptable security
requirements because users see this for everything.
>>Andy Stadler: It drives them crazy.
>>Gabe Cohen: And it drives them insane, you
want to make sure you sort of minimize the
impact while maintaining whatever your minimum
security requirements are.
Most people don't really -- we have this great
conversation about the entropy differences
in terms of security between certain length
pattern and certain length PINs, and if you
think really carefully about what your real
security requirements are, potentially you
can lower that so it's not quite as painful.
>> You will never have agreement with the
security I.T. guy and the guy on the weekend.
Your own data showed that most people weren't
locking their screens.
Thanks, guys.
>>Gabe Cohen: So I think we need to wrap up.
Let me see if we addressed some of the other
moderator questions that are here.
I think we talked about the need for unknown
sources. We addressed that. I talked about
proxy.
We talked about VPN specifically, and to this
question of, you know, device manufacturers
basically extending enterprise support, we
think this is a really great thing because
people want to use Android for work now. And
if they really want to do that, they can buy
a device that meets those needs from a manufacturer
that meets those capabilities.
I feel my personal responsibility is to look
at what the OEMs are doing to find the things
that are going to be the most common, and
make sure those are baked into the platform
because we don't want an app developer who
is talking to device management to have five
different APIs they have to deal with for
the leading OEMs to control something like
device encryption.
So we're trying to introduce standards over
time. Like we introduced encryption in Honeycomb,
as people were start to go at it on top of
Froyo.
>>Andy Stadler: And Honeycomb encryption is
a good example, actually, because we knew
how to encrypt the device but we also knew
that a lot of other OEMs were also working
on encrypting devices. And so, really -- and
it's funny, we get questions like how many
bits is the encryption and really the answer
is it just needs to be really secure and you
all know what that means. But the important
thing for us is is there an API for it. Do
we have an API and does that API really clearly
describe we are going to encrypt at least
this much of the data on the phone, and, therefore,
any OEM can wire up their encryption system
to that? That's important, because that's
what reduces fragmentation, not putting down
a bunch of mandates about you must have this
many bits or, you know, blah, blah, blah.
>>Gabe Cohen: Yeah. So we plan to control
these things basically through AOSP APIs.
>>Andy Stadler: And we're out of time.
>>Gabe Cohen: Thanks.